oh no way
we have a tie i mean it's definitely
you know just the the year of nobody
knows what's going to happen
good just nobody knows it's the most
unpredictable year
carrie underwood makes history twice
with the same award
you are the first woman who has walked
away with three
entertainer of the year awards how does
it feel holding that statue right now
it feels great um i mean obviously
there's
so many people that you know make make
our worlds go around
um so just to to be able to hold this
for
myself of course but for all of them
it's just it means a lot
and it was the first time ever
entertainer of the year ended with a tie
thomas rhett sharing the title with
carrie i like to share
i like to share with people so i just
think it's
it's just really great that you know of
course it's 20 20.
nothing's gonna be like normal terry's
an idol of mine uh
and to tie this with her it's just
absolutely unbelievable
e.t is highlighting all the best moments
from the 55th annual academy of country
music awards we are still
in the midst of trying to fight two
pandemics
cobra 19 and social injustice
far too many lives have been lost to
both keith urban kicked off the big
night with a hopeful monologue about the
healing power of country music
the songs the stories and the artists
that tell them
they bring us healing comfort and they
bring hope
and we sure could use some of that right
about now and you'd never know it was
the singer's first time hosting
i've never hosted before i've never you
know
uh you picked a hell of a year to hold
well
it was all going so well kevin um
we were supposed to be in vegas in april
and uh
instead we will be in nashville in
september but uh first and foremost i'm
glad that we're doing it i'm glad the
acms are going ahead
um it's going to be a really really good
show
keith's wife nicole kidman couldn't be
by his side but that didn't mean she
wasn't watching
i have the most extraordinary partner in
life
gwen stefani and blake shelton also
couldn't be in nashville
but ain't nothing a green screen can't
fix through the magic of television
voila welcome back to the bluebird cafe
everybody the two lovebirds gave us all
the feels as they performed their song
happy anywhere
blake took home song of the year for
god's country and thanked his
inspiration
thank you gwen stefani for continuing to
encourage me to keep
doing this and keep trying and being my
inspiration
carrie underwood took the stage at the
grand ole opry house to honor
trailblazing female opry members like
reba mcintyre
in georgia and dolly parton here
mary morris took home female artist of
the year and performed her song hell and
back
[Music]
[Applause]
i wanted to play a song that was
kind of a that met the times because i
feel like this year has been hell
for a lot of us and um and it's also had
its bright moments and silver linings
this was the 30 year old singer's first
big performance since she became a mom
in march
it's been really magical the last couple
days of rehearsals and getting to feel
like
i'm doing this again country singer
mickey guyton delivered one of the most
powerful moments of the 2020 acms
the singer who is expecting her first
child performed her song
what are you gonna tell her while keith
played the piano
what are you gonna tell her it's just a
real full circle moment
just with what's going on with women in
country radio and
around the world and it's just an honor
to
sing a song like that at the acms mickey
spoke with e.t ahead of her performance
opening up about what she was hoping to
bring to the stage as a black woman in
country
music starting my career off i never
thought of myself as some
activist i was actually always someone
that kind of just
stayed in the back and just didn't want
to make any noise or rock the boat and
then everything kind of shifted for me
and to step in that role
as a woman as a black woman it is such
an
honor that people are giving me this
opportunity to be heard
and to and to hopefully incite change
honestly it is such an honor
to me pink and keith urban rocked the
stage together as they performed their
new track
one too many for the first time
you know it the second it comes on you
just know it it's uh
she's one of the greats she literally is
one of the greats
and getting to do a song with her was
amazing taylor swift made her country
comeback
playing acoustic to her new song betty
her first time at the acm awards in
seven
[Music]
it out years weeks now but it's finally
sinking in